NOW BACK TO HANNITY.
HAVE A GREAT NIGHT.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE A VERY SERIOUS
EVENT.
WE'LL FIND OUT.
WHEN THEY LOOK AT THE DOCUMENTS,
I THINK PEOPLE WILL SEE A LOT OF
BAD THINGS HAPPENED.
I HOPE IT IS NOT SO, BECAUSE IF
IT IS, THERE IS NOTHING BEEN
ANYTHING LIKE IT IN THE HISTORY
OF OUR COUNTRY.
WE ARE CLEANING EVERYTHING UP.
IT IS SO IMPORTANT, WHAT I AM
DOING IS A SERVICE TO THIS
COUNTRY.
WE CALL IT SPYGATE.
YOU ARE CALLING IT SPYGATE.
A LOT OF BADENINGS HAVE
HAPPENED.
>> Jeanine: WELCOME BACK TO
A SPECIAL EDITION OF HANNITY.
THAT THE PRESIDENT GOING ON
OFFENSE THIS WEEK AGAINST THE
DEEP STATE.
HE DIDN'T STOP THERE.
HE SAID THE TEMDEMS ARE ALLUDING
TO THE CONCEPT HAVING AN
INFORMANT PLACED IN OPPOSING
PARTY'S CAMPAIGN IS DIFFERENT AS
HAVING A SPY.
BUT WHAT ABOUT A INFORNLANT THAT
IS PAID A FORTUNE AND WHO SETS
UP WAY EARLIER THAN A RUSSIAN
HOAX.
CAN ANYONE IMAGINE HAVING SPIES
PLACED IN A COMPETTING CAMPAIGN
BY THE PEOPLE IN ABSOLUTE POWER
FOR THE SOLE PURPOSE OF
ADVANTAGE AND GAIN.
AND THE EXPENDITURE OF FAR MORE
MONEY LOST.
THE PRESIDENT'S COMMENTS ARE
CAUSING PEOPLE TO LASH OUT.
>> WHAT IS THE INFORMANT AND
A SPY.
>> IT IS TYPICAL OF MR. TRUMP TO
MISCHARACTERIZE.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT MR. TRUMP
IS IT AS YOU SAID MASTERFUL AT
IN TERMS OF TWISTING THE TRUTH
TO SUPPORT HIS NARRATIVE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE COMPARE THAT THE
F.B.I. AND CIA DIDN'T DO ENOUGH
TO UNCOVER WHAT RUSSIA WAS
DOING.
THIS IS WHAT THE F.B.I. WAS
SUPPOSED TO DO AND THANK
GOODNESS THEY DID IT.
>> Jeanine: JOINING US WITH
REACTION, THE AUTHOR OF THE BOOK
"THE RUSSIA HOAX".
GREG HAND AND FENTON AND FOX
NEWS KRNTOR CHARLIE HURTZ.
DID THE F.B.I. HAVE A BASIS FOR
A CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION OR
SUFFICIENT INTELLIGENCE BASIS TO
LAUNCH A PROBE.
>> THEY HAD NEITHER AND THE
EVIDENCE IS CLEAR AND YET THEY
LAUNCHED THE INVESTIGATION IN
THEN CANDIDATE TRUMP AND
CONTINUED IT WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
AND SO THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHTLY
OUTRAGED AND I AM HAPPY HE
EXPRESSED IT THAT THEY USED
A SPY TO INFILTRATE HIS CAMPAIGN
AND TO ELICIT AND TO ENDUCE AND
ENTRAP PEOPLE.
IF IT WAS DONE FOR POLITICAL
REASON AND IT WAS AMAZING IT
WAS.
THAT IS A CRIME AND CALM WOULD
ABUSE OF POWER.
THEY WERE DEPRIVING CANDIDATE
RIGHTS AND HIS RIGHT TO PRIVACY
AND FOURTH AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
>> Jeanine: TOM, THERE IS A LOT
OF THE TALK ABOUT AN INFORMANT
AND A SPY.
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
AN INFORMANT AND A SPY?
>> THERE IS NO PRACTICAL
DIFFERENCE.
ON THE PART OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, THE TOP
LEADERSHIP WAS FORCED TO ADMIT
THEY HAD SOMEONE ON THE PAYROLL
OF ONE AGENCY.
MAYBE MORE THAN ONE AGENCY.
AND WHICH WOULD HAVE BEEN
WITHOUT PRECEDENT IN AT LEAST
MODERN AMERICAN HISTORY.
YOU WOULD HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE
'60s TO FIND ANYTHING SIMILAR IN
GOVERNMENT ABUSE WHEN YOU HEAR
CLAPPER AND BRENAR AND KEEPY
CRITICIZE THE PRESIDENT FOR
CRITICIZED.
THEY ARE A LIST OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE CRIMINAL AND CIVIL
LIABILITY OF WHAT WENT ON IN THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
AND BRENNAN GO CRAZY AND ATTACK
TRUMP LIKE HE IS, YOU HAVE TO
WONDER WHY ON EARTH WAS HE EVER
ALLOWED NEAR COUNTER RELATED
INTELLIGENCE AND HE OBVIOUSLY
HATED AND IT EXPLAINS WHY THEY
WENT OFF THE RAILS UNDER THE BUM
BULL ADMINISTRATION.
>> Jeanine: WHEN TOM SAID THEY
OBVIOUSLY HATED MR. TRUMP.
IT IS NOT ANY MORE CLEARER.
A INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY AND
THEY HATED PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
WHEN DEVIN NUNEZ APPEARED TO SEE
THE PRESIDENT HAD A TINFOIL HATE
AND DEVIN NUNEZ OFF HIS ROCKER
BUT IT IS COMING TO FROM
YOURICIAN.
>> EVERYONE THOUGHT HE WAS
BEHAVING BECZARLY AND MEETING
WITH IN SECURE LOCATIONS AND ALL
OF THE PRELSZ MADE FUN OF HIM.
AND WHAT WE ARE SEEING TODAY,
ALL OF THE CONCERNS THAT HE
HINTED AT A YEAR AGO, OVER
A YEAR AGO CAME TO FRUITION.
AND AS TOM POINTED OUT.
EVEN THE DEMOCRATS HAVING TO
ACKNOWLEDGE YES, THEY DID INSERT
A SPY INTO THE POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN.
AND I THINK IT IS UNPRECEDENTED.
YOU KNOW, WE HEARD OF HENCE OF
THIS KIND OF THINGS IN THE '60
AND '70s.
IT WAS NOT, I WOULD ARGUE IT IS
NOT AS BAD AND EXTENSIVE AS.
THIS THESE PEOPLE ARE GOING,
THEY WERE ACTUALLY ACTIVELY
PUNISHING PEOPLE, POLITICAL
OPPONENTS WHICH IS SHOCKING.
>> Jeanine: IT IS SHOCKING.
AND THE AMAZING PART OF IT,
GREG, YOU HAVE THE REPUBLICANS
THAT ARE LOOKING AT SOME PEOPLE
WHOSE NAMES WE HAVE ONLY HEARD
OF.
BILL PRES STAFF.
HE WAS CHANGING THE NAME FROM
GROSS NEGLIGENCE TO EXTREMELY
CAREFUL.
AND MICHAEL STIENBAC K.
AND JOHN COLOG WHATEVER HIS NAME
IS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE CALLED BEFORE
CONGRESS.
DO YOU THINK THEY WILL TAKE THE
FIFTH OR TELL US WHAT HAPPENED?
>> SO FAR THEY HAVE BEEN
OBSTRUCTING.
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TRIED
FOR A YEAR TO QUESTION HIGH
RANKING OFFICIALS OF THE F.B.I.
AND THE F.B.I. IS REFUSING.
THAT IS OBSTRUCTION MUCH
CONGRESS AND A CLASSIC TROUGH
FOR PEOPLE TO CLAIM THAT THE
F.B.I. CANNOT TALK ABOUT
A PENDING INVESTIGATION.
THAT IS TRUE EXCEPT FOR CONGRESS
WHICH HAS A CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY
AND A RIGHT UNDER A LAWFUL
SUBPEONA TO OBTAIN THIS
INFORMATION AND TELL.
IT IS OBSTRUCTION MUCH CONGRESS
TO FAIL TO COMPLY.
AND THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT TO
DEMAND AS CHIEF EXECUTIVE OF THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
>> OF THAT BRANCH.
>> THE DOY AND F.B.I. COMPLY
WITH THE LAW.
>> Jeanine: I HAVE GIVEN YOU
CREDIT IN THE PAST THAT YOU HAVE
DONE THINGS THAT CONGRESS HASN'T
DONE.
IT IS YOUR DETERMINATION OF
TRYING TO GET RECORDS THAT GOT
THINGS THAT CONGRESS HASN'T BEEN
ABLE TO GET.
SO RIGHT NOW, WE'VE GOT THE
F.B.I. AND DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
WHO STONE WALLING, SLOW WALKING
AND SAYING THEY DON'T HAVE
RECORDS WHEN THEY DO HAVE
RECORDS AND THEY HAVE BEEN
LYING.
WHAT DOES THE PRESIDENT DO AT
THIS POINT?
HE IS THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE AND
F.B.I. AND JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
ARE UNDER HIM.
AND WHAT SHOULD HE DO TO GET IT
OUT.
NORDER A MANDATORY
DECLASSIFICATION REVIEW OF THE
DOCUMENTS WITHIN A DECENT AMOUNT
OF TIME AND HAVE OUTSIDE EXPERTS
THAT HE TRUSTS REVIEW THESE
RECORDS AND MAKE SURE NOTHING IS
HELD INPROPERLY.
WE ARE WAITING ON THE TEXT
MESSAGE.
THERE IS A PROCESS IN COURT FOR
THE TEXT MESSAGES.
HE CAN ORDER THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND F.B.I. TO COMPLY
WITH THE TRANSPARAMILITARY
WITH THE TRANSPARAMILITAR
WITH THE TRANSPARENILITAR
WITH THE TRANSPARENCYITAR
WITH THE TRANSPARENCY TAR
WITH THE TRANSPARENCY LAR
WITH THE TRANSPARENCY LAW.
THEY ARE PROTECTING THE MUELLER
OPERATION WHICH HAS ITS LODGES
IN ALL OF THE SPYING AND FISA
WARRANT AND NATIONAL SECURITY
LETTER AND TAKING UP THE PHONE
RECORDS AND UNMASKING AND USE OF
CLINTON DOSSIER.
THAT IS PART OF MUELLER'S
OPERATION AND WHY THEY ARE
RESISTING CONGRESS.
AND THEY KNOW IF IT IS UNCOVERED
MUELLER'S OPERATION ENDS.
>> Jeanine: I AM NOT CRITICAL OF
THOSE IN CONGRESS WHO ARE DOING
WHAT THEY CAN.
BUT IT IS IT TIME TO GET IT
RECOMMENDING.
IT IS TIME FOR CONSEQUENCE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THAT'S WHY
DONALD TRUMP IS PRESIDENT.
I WILL GO TO YOU, CHARLIE, WHAT
DO YOU SAY TO THOSE PEOPLE WHO
SAY THESE ARE MORE HEARINGS TO
MAKE THE DEMOCRATS TO LOOK BAD
AND GET THEM TO TESTIFY AND IT
IS PROTECTIVE NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUE.
>> THEY ARE ALL STALLING AND
LOOK AT THE THINGS, I WOULD CALL
THEM CRIMES COMMITTED IN THE
CAMPAIGN, AND AFTER THE
CAMPAIGN, WHY DID THEY DO IT?
THE REASON THEY DID IT WITH
ABANDON, BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT
HILLARY CLINTON WOULD WIN THE
ELECTION AND NONE OF IT WOULD
COME TO LIGHT AND IT WOULD NOT
MATTER.
>> Jeanine: WE KNOW THAT.
WHAT DO WE DO NOW?
>> THEY THINK THEY ARE GOING TO
WIN CONTROL IN NOVEMBER AND THEN
THEY WILL COVER IT UP.
I THINK TOM FENTON IS RIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD BEGIN
DECLASSIFICATION AND BLOW IT OUT
IN TO HAVE A HOW DOWN.
THESE PEOPLE DO WORK FOR THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
THEY ARE ANSWERABLE TO THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH.
>> Jeanine: GREG FINAL QUESTION
TO YOU.
SIGNIFICANCE OF STRZOK NOT
TESTIFYING, IS HE COOPERATING?
>> NO, IF I WERE HIM I WILL
COOPERATE.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO TELL THE
TRUTH.
HE'S IN SERIOUS LEGAL JEOPARDY.
BUT THIS IS A CLASSEC COVER UP
THAT IS TAKING PLACE IN
WASHINGTON.
THEY CLAIM THE MANTEL OF
CLASSIFIED.
AND WE FIND OUT LATER THAT WAS
A LIE.
>> Jeanine: GREG, YOU KNOW WE
HAVE AN ABSENT ATTORNEY GENERAL